Andrew Tate claims to own a fleet of
luxury cars he arrived at court in the
back of a police van
here appealing to be released from
detention he emerged handcuffed and
looking serious while his brother
Tristan waved cheerfully at reporters
The Matrix has attacked both were
arrested at the end of December they're
accused of rape people trafficking and
organized crime
after a five-hour hearing their lawyer
told me the brothers maintained they
were innocent
they were not freed instead they'll
remain in this Detention Center until at
least the end of January
with all these chicks just stuck in our
house sitting there bored completely in
love with me and of course they don't go
out they're not allowed out
Andrew Tate is a self-proclaimed
misogynist who's outspoken online dire
tribes have given him notoriety
condemnation and millions of online
followers particularly among young men
it's alleged he lured women to this
property in Romania and forced them to
work in his pornography business
he boasted of his successor machismo and
showed off his wealth supercars and
house
but now everything has been seized by
the police well from the outside this
looks like a pretty drab
Ugly Warehouse in a Dusty street but
pair through the gate and you can see
the trappings of money and luxury living
Romanian police say this property is at
the center of a web of criminality
Tate says he moved to Romania because
its laws are more lacks but here like
elsewhere he is a very divisive
character this guy Andrew Tate if I say
this name what what do you say what do
you think of her I'm rolling back my
eyes I don't like him at all I can say
that I hate him I do see why people
would admire such a character he speaks
very fluently
a lot of kids may look up to Someone
Like This
with this persona
I don't know I don't see why people
would hate him
hey the Tates maintain their only guilty
of being Brash and Unapologetic but they
are now back behind bars accused a
callous criminality
Adam Parsons Sky News Bucharest